and Syrian customs officials have seized
the assets of the country's wealthiest
businessman is the first time an order
has been issued for Rami Makhlouf who's
the cousin of President Bashar al-assad
he's been accused of importing products
including oil and gas without paying
charges and fees the EU and us have
already imposed sanctions on bacliff who
reportedly controls 60 percent of
Syria's economy Chris Doyle is a Middle
East analyst and director of the Council
for Arab British understanding he
explains why Makhlouf may have been
targeted the much blue family right at
the center the core of this regime
remember that Hafiz Allah said that's
the father of Bashar al-assad was not
married to Anissa Makhlouf which is in
the maklouf soiree an ally we clan as
well as the assets and in fact in many
ways of greater social standing and
mohamed mahmoud was the father of Rami
was very much the regime's banker he is
extremely rich so to see the regime
taking action like this against somebody
so senior and indeed others who were
part of this new crony capitalism that
had underpinned the regime
demet demonstrates that all is not well
in the inner echelons of power now
there's a number of scenarios one can
consider here there is an extent the
regime is trying to shore up its
legitimacy at a time of real declining
revenues when so many Syrians are
destitute or below the poverty line and
are resentful of those who have billions
who actually show off their wealth and
in a way and we've seen this also with
the macula family they have been
prepared to that they've been all sorts
of stories on social media and pictures
of some of their family with fast cars
and the like so this is resented it
could also be that given the regime has
so little financial resource at the
moment that they are trying to basically
Corral in as many millions and billions
as they can